rumors are flying that Diane Kruger and
Norman Reedus are more than just friends
but a source tells ET they are not
dating or hooking up and that Diane is
still with longtime boyfriend Joshua
Jackson the two have hit several red
carpets together recently
Kruger treatise and Jackson all-star
together in the movie sky but an
eyewitness does tell ET Diane was
sitting on Norman's lap at a party for
the movie in September and that they
were practically inseparable all night
her hand was around him in the back of
his pants the source says in an
affectionate girlfriendy way they seemed
like they were more than just friends
that party was at the Toronto
International Film Festival Jackson
didn't appear to be at that party but
did hit up an event with Kruger the
following day perhaps ironically
Jackson's stars on Showtime's the affair
his character gets cheated on on the
sexy show here's what he told ET just
weeks ago how does ayan feel about those
more steamy scenes on the show well I
mean the show might be steamy but it's
so tremendously dysfunctional that I
don't think she feels threatened by
anything that's happening on camera and
thank God she's an actress as well so
she understands